I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich. This is radio lab today,
a whole hour on the Galapagos Islands.
The place that inspired Charles Darwin to create his theory of evolution,
whose basic ingredients are lots of time isolation and then constant change.
But Darwin didn't consider this possibility.
What if on these islands Feldman's of tourists arrive every day carrying fruits
and chocolates and souvenirs, jumping from island to island.
Now the Galapagos government spends millions of dollars checking all of the
goods that come in and out trying to quarantine the ones that might have things
that are a problem.
But what if simply putting your foot on the ground can completely transform it?
The place
I love going back to producer Tim Howard.
So I met this woman named Hika Yeager who is, uh,
like a plant scientist time there,
restoration ecologist at the Charles Darwin Foundation.
And here we are in and mellows.
We were going to look at these incredible craters called Los Halos. Ooh,
I almost got hit by a car. And as we're walking along the path, let's see, she,
she's like, oh wait, look at this here.
She points just to the right of the path. Look at this species here.
Small leafy green thing. They call it [inaudible] 10 and Spanish.
It is in its plan.
Plantago I think in the u s they call it the um,
was it the wrench of the white man?
The range of the white man. It's actually the footprint of the white man.
It doesn't matter. Point is an introduced species. It's introduced,
it's found in Europe. North Africa shouldn't be here and you have this one here.
She points right next to it. It's called Titus Canthia CRB thing.
Green and white leaves has a terrible common name and English.
I'm not going to sand wandering Jew basic house plant.
You can buy it at home depot. But uh, there it is in the Galapagos and um,
along this path,
just looking to the right and the left and then she's just starts counting the
number of invasive species at one, two, three, four. As you can see here,
it's only right next to the trail, but not so much for them.
You will see that they're only there for this border of about five to 10 inches
along the edge of that path. Why? Why would that be?
Because Heikki said what happens is that Taurus,
they'll be back in their home country,
there'll be walking around in a garden or a park and it'll be filled with tiny
seeds.
The seeds stick to shoes and socks and trousers.
They wear the trousers on the plane and then they wear them when they come here
and then people walk and then just distribute.
I would just post the seats along the trail.
And now most of these plants are actually probably harmless and you know,
like you said, Galapagos National Park, they spend tons of money,
tons of time trying to keep invasives out.
But the fact is there's only so much you can do and every once in a while one of
these hitchhikers slips under the radar and just wreaks havoc.
You just grabbed it just like that. You just put your hands around. Yeah.
That's the only possible the first day.
So while we were in the highlands of Santa Cruz,
Hunky took me through the woods to meet this guy named Arno.
My name is [inaudible]. Adam is an ornithologist from the University of Vienna.
And shortly after we walked up,
he reached out into this tree and he grabbed this tiny little baby fins right
off the branch is the dorm. Well, he says, oh my God. He said,
he, he looks a little bit furry, almost really tiny vulnerable, uh,
fledgling of a warbler. Finch.
The wall briefings is the smallest of the Darwin's finches you can like see him
pulsing kind of as he's breathing.
So Darwin's finches in short, Darwin,
when he visited Galapagos, he collected a lot of specimens of finches,
took them back to England, and eventually he realized that
the beaks had all adapted.
They were all a little bit different depending on which island the finches lived
on with the beaks. Beaks adapted to whatever the thing was they were eating.
One island finches had literally like the beak would be shaped sort of long.
And then the next island it would look almost the same, but much shorter.
And this became one of the,
one of the most important pieces of evidence that you know,
when animals would move from one place to another,
that they would begin to differentiate based on what cities are very,
very important. Yes.
But speaking of beaks, that finch, that Arno was holding, just the Fred,
his beak that you see,
the specially this side is extremely huge. Yeah.
Oh, the nostrils. Nostrils have have big holes. Yeah.
[inaudible]
oh, something had gotten inside this little finch,
his nostrils drilled these holes and it was no eating the flesh on the inside of
the birds nostrils.
Scientists first began to see this in 1997 when they started to find nests full
of dead baby finches. At first,
nobody had any idea what kind of creature it was.
So they began to frantically study it.
[inaudible]
I actually visited one of the main researchers, PA doddling Congo.
I keep the name of [inaudible].
She's lived in Galapagos for over a decade and she showed me her lab.
I'm surrounded by shelves and on the shelves
there are these tiny little plastic cups that are filled with, um,
flies. This is the villain
better, but I said Solo qualcare people, they most,
a little black fly looks like every other flies.
[inaudible] in fact,
[inaudible] says [inaudible] that it's actually in the same family as the
regular house fly, but it's actually a bot fly called
Jordan is down. Z. Can you just spell Florence down? Z? Yeah, it's p.
H. I. L. I can't spell out loud. Fail Lore.
L. O. R. N. I. S. D. O. W. N. S. I. Okay. Huh.
[inaudible] actually means bad loving. That's Charlotte Coston.
She's a researcher at the Charles Darwin Foundation. She says,
there's actually very little known about the fly.
They're not sure where it came from or quite how it got here.
But here's what they do know.
[inaudible]
the adult fly seems to be harmless, yet a fly is actually vegetarian.
It feeds on flowers and we think decomposing fruits,
baby flies. They're not vegetarian. That will, you know, suck blood.
And what happens is that, um, as soon as I start laying eggs,
mother flies swoop in and lay their eggs on the base of the nest,
sort of underneath the finch eggs. Once the eggs hatch,
the eggs hatch of the flies as well.
And the larvae wriggling little larva will crawl out from the bottom of the nest
of the finches body into its beat and they go into the noses and,
um, of the baby finches and just started eating. You know,
they're basically, um, feed on the blood of the, the baby birds.
How did these little fly babies? No, I mean, that's a,
that's an a very specific trip to take. Good question.
We're still trying to figure that out. Um, you know,
we assume that it was carbon dioxide,
carbon dioxide from the breathing of the bed. Oh yeah.
Well, they didn't want [inaudible] of boxes.
Some of the birds that little, um, being Saunas, the finches.
Oh God. It's the noise. Not the man.
Pa Dad showed me this tiny little dead finch in the spot.
[inaudible] wow. There's a little hole into the brain of this little finch.
Oh my God. We'll go in there in a nice spa.
They ate the whole back of this little finch to how big a problem is this?
Well, I talked to One scientist,
Sonia Klein for I'm professor in animal behavior at Flinders university South
Australia.
And she told me that researchers recently did a survey of finch nests for
different species on two islands and all research groups found about 95%
mortality in the nest.
95% of the babies were dead. Yeah.
And our note told me that this year of small treif inches.
So far we had only two nests with fledglings and all that as well.
So it's a lot. Yeah. But even worse so far,
we found file on us on 13 islands.
The flies spreading island to island. Is there any,
any timescale we should we worry about like are these finches disappearing very
fast? Very slowly. Depends on the species.
We have at least five species that are known to be facing extinction and another
six in serious decline. These five species,
does that mean that they may go extinct in the next five years and the next 50
years? I have not. Um, you know,
we have the case that the mango fence, we have 60 to 80 individuals left.
Wow. It's a race against time.
[inaudible]
so for starters,
they put up all these tracks and [inaudible] they took me outside,
they showed me where the traps are.
Trap hanging from a tree here and you see them actually all over Santa Cruz,
these bright yellow traps hanging from trees, the school named [inaudible].
And this is to control the fly population? No, no.
They would need like millions of traps every few feet to do that.
This is just to grab a few flies, take them back
to the lab and study them so they can learn how to fight them.
Charlotte and PA Dodd's fantasy is that the flies use a pheromone to attract the
opposite sex signing testicle.
It would be lovely if we could find something like that because if they could
find that chemical,
that love chemical that the flies used to attract each other,
they could disrupt it, confused the flies and screw up their mating.
Another possibility is sterile insect technique,
sterilize male flies and introduce them back into the wild. So the female, um,
mates with a stair fly and obviously it doesn't produce fertile eggs.
If they can't make babies, the population will crash.
And in some cases you can successfully eradicate a species.
This is very much like the mosquitoes that Andy talked about a couple of
podcasts ago. Right? But here's the problem.
[inaudible] if they're gonna release their allies, male flies into the wild.
They have to be able to raise
inclusively millions of these fights in the lab.
And they're trying like crazy showing me all of the larvas that hatch today and
the dodge with me for baby flies that had just hatched and they're in these
little cup tea.
But she told me that these four flies will
probably die because they always die.
Right now we have huge problems trying to rear fylantis and captivity,
which is ironic given you know how abundant it is in the wild
[inaudible] when I was there,
he had told me that so far they had only successfully raised three,
three doll flies when you were saying they needed millions. Yeah.
And meanwhile, the finch populations are just getting decimated.
Charlotte says that they're trying to respond.
Ornithologists have started to notice some new behaviors, for instance,
set up as picking the Lafayette or the nostrils of the baby beds.
And what we're starting to see is that they're beginning to consume them.
You mean eat the fly lower? Yeah.
Which 15 years ago they would never do back in the year 2000 Sonia and some
colleagues tried feeding the finches some fly larva.
And if ever there were a look of disgust on a finch phase, that was it.
So I think there's been a change there.
Also seeing baby finches climbing up over each other,
just struggling to get away from the larva on the bottom of the nest. Um,
and they'll even start standing on the nest room just to avoid being eaten by
it. When I asked Charlotte what she makes of all of these changes, she said, um,
I think probably too little, too late.
[inaudible]
but then Sonia told me something really surprising. Yeah. That,
that was a very unexpected discovery. Takes a couple steps to get there,
but just to set it up,
back in 2000 she was on flurry on an island for the first time I started
studying Darwin's finches in particular three tree finch species, the small,
the medium and the large.
And we went out and we set up our mis nets and we caught the birds and we
measured them.
And the thing to know is that even though these are three different species,
they're actually really hard to tell apart visually.
So she would end up relying on their songs, their mating calls.
Do you remember the song types? Could you whistle them for me? Oh yes. It's,
it's a very simple song. The small tree finch goes something like two, two,
two two two two two
[inaudible].
That's a small tree finch and the,
the medium tree finch is just a bit slower for the medium as a t,
t t t for the large g, g
G. T. Wow.
It's like a soprano saxophone and an alto and a 10 or something like that.
That's right. So we, we just, you know, sat in the forest and were,
and we would always quiz each other. What's that? What's that?
And we all agreed because the calls are really distinct, easy to tell apart.
But the interesting thing was from year to year it got more difficult.
As Tony says, each time she'd go into the field,
the song sounded like they were starting to blur together.
Then when I showed up after a few years, again,
I was truly even more perplexed. Should I go?
Why can't I tell these finches apart? It was very confusing.
Am I losing my touch? But that shouldn't really happen.
You should actually get better with experience. Not Worse.
And that's where I thought, oh, something's changed in the system.
I like to think of it as a kind of, um, Darwin finch, you know, slew thing,
adventure. So Sonya and your team rounded up some of the birds they tagged,
we collected genetic samples, got some DNA and song samples,
made some recordings, brought all this stuff into the lab,
analyze the genetic samples and had this terrible realization that the large
tree finches now extinct. Totally gone from the island.
So you really only had two species left.
You had the small tree finches and the medium tree finches,
and based on that genetic data, the small trees
benches not doing great,
but compared to the medium tree finches they are because the medium tree finches
were on the brink of extinction like a large ones. Yeah.
But then she sees something amazing in that genetic data.
She sees a small group of birds who have mixed up genes,
a hybrid cluster,
some genes from the small tree finches and some from the medium tree finches.
What does that mean? Well,
it means that these two different finches had started having babies together,
which should never actually happen because these are totally separate species.
That's really the classical definition of a species is like a biological rule
about who you're not going to make a baby with. So they,
they choose not to breed even if they could for who knows,
maybe a million years. The medium tree finch has patrolled that boundary.
I've got my thing over here, and you got your thing over there,
but then along come the flies and all of a sudden,
like over maybe 20 years, these medium tree finches,
they start to break their own biggest rule and they start to meet outside of
their own kind. And these hybrid finches,
are they doing better against the flies? Well, there's,
there's a couple of clues that say maybe, yeah. For example, when you look at
in the nest,
they seem to have fewer parasites and they seem to have more babies that survive
15% wow.
Whereas the numbers were very small for the medium tree finch and smaller for
the small tree finch. Wow. I dare say that sounds kind of hopeful.
It does. Yeah. Now, the jury is still very much out on what will happen,
but if the hybrids do have a fitness advantage and if they survive,
we may be witnessing in hyperspeed the creation of an entirely new species.
It would possibly be one of the first vertebrate examples of speciation in real
time that we can observe.
So tucked into the story of these finches
is this story of Galapagos.
Uh,
same exact story that Darwin saw. These processes that you've described
[inaudible]
they just never ever stopped.
It's this on ending
struggle.
[inaudible]
one last thing. My last night there,
I went to meet up with that guy, Lou Nitas, who is running for mayor.
I met him at this pizza place. The election had happened the night before.
And did he win? No. A Buccellati the incumbent one. So we,
we go outside. Chad [inaudible] paralysis. I was running as the mayor.
Turns out he speaks some English. So we, you know,
we do this interview in English and I'm,
I'm almost embarrassed that I wanted to talk to him because I think that dude is
just going to be so down and out. Exactly the opposite.
He was so joyful to have lost. That's what I thought. You're not sad.
You're not sad. And he's like, friend, this is a field of four.
The other three have money behind them.
And you see their flags all over Santa Cruz. I just came in second. Whoa.
The guy who wins. He spent $500,000 I spent what, two grand?
No, a friend.
The beginning is DV inning of a new,
a new future for the Galapagos island.
We are ascended and we keep, we have our dreams.
So nature has a boys. Now the sea lion has a boys in us,
the tortoise as a boys in the penguin in every way. So something is happening.
That's exactly how he sees it. So thank you very much for the interview.
I hope you enjoy the Galapagos island.
[inaudible] 10 now, before we close,
very special thanks to Matthew, Judas kilty,
without whom Tim would have been crushed just by the sheer amount of tape that
he gathered. Indeed. Also, thanks to Dylan Key for original music.
Thanks to Trisha
bellmen and screen siren pictures. Alex Galfond, Matthias Espinosa,
the naturals guide from the first chapter who wrote this song, peak open zone.
He's also a well known musician in Galapagos.
Turns out thanks to the Galapagos National Park,
Charles Darwin Foundation island conservation and the Galapagos conservancy.
I'm Chan up and Rod I Robert Krulwich.